أه عرض الوقت يا رفاق أنكم
مستعدون ، يقول إن POTUS هذا هو المكان الذي أتى
من
المدرب وضعني فيه ، أنا جاهز للعب
يا رفاق ، أعرف أنك المستضعف
ولكني سأخبرك ما هو الرجل الذي حصلت عليه من
بعض أفضل اللاعبين في  عالم في
فريقك وأنت تمثل هذا
البلد وأنا أعلم أنك
ستلعب بقلوبك ، لذا دعنا نصدمهم ،
كل ما تثق به بعضكما البعض
يلعب بأقصى ما يمكنك وأنت تعرفه
لك ولعائلتك  زملائك في
الفريق وكل البلاد تجذير لك
هذه رسالة لطيفة للغاية السيد
الرئيس ، الفريق بأكمله هنا
الآن نحن نقدر دعمك حقًا
ونحن مستعدون للذهاب يا رفاق تريد أن
تقول مرحبًا ،
شكرًا
لك على حصولك على أي مما
حصلت عليه  لقد حصلت على بعض منه الكثير
من الشكر والكثير من الترحيب ، أتمنى أن
أكون هناك لأراك ، أنا
حقًا أحضرهم يا رفاق فقط لعبوا قلوبكم ،
لقد حصلنا على هذا ، أعلم أنك سوف أعرف أنك
ستفعل
كل شيء  كان هذا لطيفًا ، أليس كذلك
[تصفيق]